all right let's go to jacob in seattle
washington jacob what's going on
i just got engaged with my girlfriend
and
we are in the first stages of looking at
what to plan for budget for a wedding
congratulations man any kind of
guidelines or anything thank you
oh man you were talking to two people
who probably did this very differently
number one jacob where are you guys
financially are you bringing debt in the
marriage you have any savings you have
cash who's paying for the wedding give
me a little background
so i am currently in baby step three and
i'm i
have just been lazy in terms of putting
my my money forward to getting through
my baby step three so i've got about
three thousand dollars
out of my three six months that's about
one and a half months right now for me
and then she has a ten thousand dollar
car debt and that's
it for uh okay that's awesome she makes
about
thirty five thousand dollars a year and
i'm about fifty five thousand dollars a
year
okay and who's who's responsible for
paying for the wedding
um it's gonna be solely on us my parents
have
shown interest in wanting to help but i
don't know what they're actually gonna
be able to contribute and i'm not really
expecting anything
okay so we're in february when are you
guys getting married
um we're waiting we're thinking about
maybe waiting until covet
is over but i mean that's kind of why
we're asking about
the budgeting and the the money work
like version of it so we can kind of
think where
we need to be in terms of how much time
we have to save up and what you guys
recommend for that so
you don't have a date or anything set
okay well i never
give a specific dollar amount by any
means or uh
or even a percentage so i i would say
for you guys what you can pause right
now and if you just
saved as much as possible for the next
nine months
whatever that would be um and have that
amount of cash there to say okay we have
the ability to spend all of this on a
wedding
or we can spend half of this money on a
wedding we can take the other half
and put it towards the 10 000 car loan
after we get married and pay off debt
and be in a better place financially all
of that so
the thing with weddings is you can go
real
expensive you can go real cheap we had
friends that got married
during covet on zoom they literally were
like you know what we're just gonna get
past her and they texted us like get on
at 6 p.m we're just gonna get married
and and i know that's not everyone's cup
of tea but part of me was like i kind of
love that like
oh man yes that sounds incredible so
just don't go
just don't go crazy pay cash number one
and what you guys can say towards the
wedding
have that amount of money because you
can emotionally get attached to some of
that cash to say oh
let's not spend it all and just don't be
emotional about your decisions
yeah and also don't be afraid to get
married in a smaller ceremony
and a year and a half from now two years
from now when all the smoke is hopefully
clearing on all this
you can have the party of a lifetime
yeah don't wait on kovac
you know what i mean if you love her
okay y'all just get married just do it
and then it's the year of 2020 2021.
you'll look back until your grandkids
yeah that's right pandemic and then
two years later i had the party of a
century that we paid for in cash